まあからチロルチョコ知ってますかはいチロルチョコすごい種類があると思うんですよ
僕のてキャラ多すぎて味れ中今回きなこも辛くとか絶妙なラインバックで突いていくん
ですね
ワンちゃんでも同じなんじゃないかなってる気がしておりまして名前何味って書いて
あるから何味なんだなってコーチがはまあまあかかってしまってヲタが来るわーさー
じゃないの
に黒あさっててるかな黒坂んだみたいな認識のこと食べてしまうからサーチとかんって
しまってう気がしているんですけど微妙な違いはあるものの実際味が全部同じなんじゃ
ないかということで結構いろんな苦労さんだ
結構いろんなチロルチョコ準備してあるんだって増加に今回県そうしたいのチロル
チョコの味がわかんない僕に何が一つロチ
を食べさせてくださいでそのゲーム音楽水好きな味で言ったけど本当に育ちでもいいっ
ス市が打ってもいいってさあなに味かをて人に僕に言って取りガートナー人なのか
また違う味なんだと僕があったらこれで全然あたらなかったらもうスロチョコはを完全
に
全然難しくないこれレナーで片手のあればもすっごくですか
本当はちょっと検証していこうと思いますでは以降吉広
[音楽]
ピョンん
朝鳥ですねオーソドックスである愛していきますはいこれはミルクあるで
魅力はへ本当に誰かのミルクれる牛乳のあんじゃん
ブーッ
うーん
どうぞ
ええええええ
どこだねうーんいうことうん
配管等ございました a オレは
[音楽]
ミルクはずです
by $ author ファイバーロンドンた世界シャー
ブーブーいいっ
[音楽]
潰せないですうわぁな予感な
うーん例が美味しいうん美味しいけどこう
確固たるクロワッサンよみんなせればそうそう苦労さんって味ある
えっふわぁプレ卍くださいと添えました生え
ではどうぞ
今のはん
黒バスさの足です
ファイナルアンサーマイナーなんだ the ええええええウソウソウソ
黒あったんじゃないんですね絶対配ったんですよ逆に当ててほしい
何味か正解はざー7周
て分のシュプリームな
物理とってなかった相次ぎこれです
シャアバッハ
んあなんかヌルヌルしてるっ
ん
はいございました抑えてええん
[音楽]
おそらく15時だと思いませんやなーさー目立った
せーん
怪異
唯えっただただのストロベリーじゃないさっきの塗る振って来たんで当てて言い当てて
チョコストロベリーでしょう
ブーブー言っ n 4プロパティ
いいんでした
持った
よし強いこれは5 up 分集合
戻ってきた7数集めると思う
[音楽]
あわかりましたはい7種ではなく
はい closer 慈誠会 year
なんでこれだけは買ったねん
[音楽]
me
うううう
ええええええ
me
me あった